Organic chemistry is based on carbon containing molecules with CH bonds,
so some joke that organic chemists see the entire periodic table as carbon except for a few other key
elements. Now, the stereotype kind of makes sense.
Organic chemistry arose as a discipline to describe the chemistry of life and the elements contained within the human body are
concentrated in this upper right portion of the periodic table, but if we're talking about biochemistry, there are other elements that are important as well.
Trace elements in the human body include the transition metals, and
many of the reactants that you'll meet in organic chemistry 1 & 2 span the entire periodic table. All
that being said, I'm going to give into stereotypes for a moment
and we're going to focus on the bonding of elements in the upper right-hand portion of the periodic table because these are the most likely
eements to be bonded to carbon in organic molecules. Let's briefly review the octet rule.
Most elements like to have eight electrons around them.
This includes all of the electrons that are shared in
bonds. There are many exceptions to this, of course, and a notable one is hydrogen,
which only makes one bond and therefore has two electrons around itself. If you're not allowed to use a
periodic table to complete your exam,
it's wise to memorize the periodic table going over from carbon to fluorine and down the halogens.
You can use my silly acronym: Can Normal Owls Fly, or come up with your own.
Going from left to right the number of valence electrons that the element prefers to have
increases, and now we get to our little trick.
Starting with carbon we can count down from four and we get the number of bonds that the element likes to form when it is
neutral.
Now phosphorus and sulfur also follow this rule
but they're special cases
because they have empty d orbitals they can actually exceed an octet of electrons around them.
So phosphorus, when neutral, will form either three or five bonds and sulfur can form two, four, or six
bonds to other atoms when neutral.
Let's look at a simple example of a molecule containing an element from each group
so we can correlate the number of valence electrons with a number of bonds that the element likes to make.
Here I've drawn out methane with a pair of dots to represent the two electrons that are shared in the bond to hydrogen. In
organic chemistry, it's more conventional to show the pair of electrons as a single line
connecting the two atoms.
Keep in mind that each of these lines is representing a pair of electrons.
Now, to count valence electrons,
we can think about splitting the bond in half and thinking carbon "owns" half of the electrons in each bond.
Since carbon likes to have four valence electrons carbon is neutral in methane. Now, let's move on to ammonia, NH3.
We see that nitrogen likes to make three bonds when it's neutral and we have three bonds to hydrogen in the structure of ammonia.
However, nitrogen likes to have five valence electrons, and we only have three coming from bonds.
This is because nitrogen contains a lone pair—when an atom has a lone pair
you count the lone pair as belonging just to that atom itself, and so we have five valence electrons on nitrogen.
We can look at the structure of water to explore the valence of oxygen.
Oxygen is neutral when it makes two bonds so bonded to these two hydrogen atoms, we have a neutral molecule of water.
But its valence is six. This is because oxygen has two lone pairs, so in water
oxygen is the "owner" of four electrons from lone pairs and half of the bonds to hydrogen. That's six valence electrons.
For our fluorine example we're going to look at hydrofluoric acid. This is a weak acid, but a really toxic molecule.
Fluorine likes to make one bond when neutral but it also likes to have seven valence electrons,
so fluorine gets three lone pairs.
This gives it six electrons in lone pairs plus one from the bond to hydrogen. This is seven valence electrons.
If we simplify our periodic table even more to remove the left and the right hand groups,
we can come up with a trick to figure out the formal charge on an element. The number of bonds the element likes to form
when neutral is still written across the top of the table.
Now, if the element is making one extra bond it is going to be positively charged,
and if it's making one less bond it's going to be negatively charged.
Let's look at water once again as our neutral example. Water wants to have six valence electrons
and it has four coming from the lone pair and two coming from bonds. The hydronium ion is a better way to represent
H+, or a
proton, in an acidic solution.
Now we have three bonds to oxygen
but we don't want to break the octet rule
We still only want to have eight total electrons around our central element.
So now oxygen has only one lone pair and a formal positive charge on oxygen.
Okay, let's count our valence electrons to see how we figure this out.
We already said we have six valence electrons in water. Now with the hydronium ion,
we have two electrons coming from lone pairs.
We also have three electrons coming from the six electrons that are shared in bonds. Remember,
oxygen "owns" half of the electrons in the bond. If
we add this up, we see that oxygen has five valence electrons total. Well,
this is one less negative charge than the six valence electrons
It likes to have when neutral. So, if we have one less negative—one less electron—
oxygen has a formal positive charge.
Alright, so we looked at an example where oxygen is making three bonds—one extra bond—and therefore has positive charge.
Let's look at an example where it's making one less bond and has a formal negative charge.
Hydroxide is a
deprotonated form of water that exists in basic solutions.
Let's count electrons. We have just one electron coming from the bond to hydrogen.
Oxygen is only sharing electrons in one bond, so to complete its octet we need to add three lone pairs.
With the one electron from the shared bond, and the six electrons from lone pairs, we get seven valence electrons
on oxygen.
This is one more electron than oxygen likes to have when neutral. If we have one extra negative charge,
we get a formal minus charge on oxygen.
Let's return to our original piece of the periodic table for a moment that we were looking at.
This formal charge trick works for all of the elements in the middle three groups,
so it will work for nitrogen and phosphorous, oxygen and sulfur, and the halogens.
But it doesn't work for carbon. Let's see why.
Carbon likes to have four groups around it. I'm
going to label these groups "R".
This is a convention used in organic chemistry when we don't want to specifically define what the group is.
Now if we think about losing "R" but leaving its electrons behind on
carbon we get an extra lone pair on carbon.
This gives carbon five valence electrons, therefore the atom carries a formal negative charge.
Now if we think about carbon ionizing by losing the R group
with a pair of electrons we get a different story.
Carbon now has just three valence electrons.
It wants to have four, so it's missing one negative charge and it takes on a formal positive charge
itself. This species is called a carbocation, and it ALSO has three bonds.
So you can see why our formal charge trick doesn't quite work with carbon. In
this lesson, we looked at the valence of atoms that are most likely to be bonded to carbon in
organic molecules.
We looked at some simple examples
and figured out how to determine
how many lone pairs are on each atom.
We also looked at a trick for figuring out formal charge on the groups to the right of carbon and
saw why this trick can't be applied to carbon itself.
We'll look at the bonding of many more elements and practice Lewis structures in another lesson.
KP here. If you learned something give me a thumbs up on the way out and for more chemistry subscribe to my channel.